diese nachricht erreicht uns gerade eben
aus kiew es gab einen raketenangriff auf
den fernsehturm der hauptstadt russische
streitkräfte also beschießen nach
angaben des ukrainischen
innenministeriums den fernsehturm von
care4 auch die bilder ja der touren der
wurde bisher wohl noch nicht getroffen
wie es aus ersten aufnahmen hervor geht
aber er war wohl ziel dieses angriffs ja
und nach den bildern die wir uns
vorliegen die über twitter reinkommen
die wir inzwischen verifizieren konnten
und die das innenministerium bestätigt
sieht es aus als wenn es mehrere
angriffe gegeben hat aber der
fernsehturm steht noch nach diesen
bildern jedenfalls gehen wir direkt nach
kiew zu unseren reportern peter hell und
paul ronzheimer die uns bei der jetzt
zugeschaltet sind paul familie an wie
hast du diesen angriff erlebt was hast
du davon mitbekommen
thomas wir waren ja mehrere kilometer
davon entfernt muss man sagen das liegt
dieser
fernsehturm liegt in der nähe eines
gedenkt zentrums für holocaust-opfer
bienia das ist eine gedenkstätte
ausgerechnet in dieser nähe wurde dieser
fernsehturm getroffen man hat ein
schläge gehört tatsächlich ist es das
worauf sich die stadt seit heute morgen
seit heute mittag vorbereitet
ursprünglich aber hatte man erwartet
dass wladimir putin zunächst ein
geheimdienst gebäude das haupt
geheimdienst gebäude
bombardieren würde denn die spd der
ukrainische geheimdienst sollte ziel
sein das war bekannt gegeben worden mit
dem hinweis dass sich zivilisten von
dort entfernen sollten jetzt der tv turm
das ist das klassische vorgehen der
russischen armee zunächst einmal die
möglichkeit zu nehmen in den
tv-stationen weiterhin über das zu
berichten was wirklich passiert und dann
davon gehen alle aus wird man auch
versuchen sozusagen handynetze und
internet hier anzugreifen und zu stören
um dann die kommunikation mit den
menschen am außer kraft zu setzen das
ist das vorgehen der russischen armee zu
beobachten auch in anderen regionen
dieser welt wir gehen davon aus dass das
heute der staat sein könnte eines großen
angriff auf die hauptstadt hier weiter
zu peter hell peter du hast du diesen
angriff auch miterlebt und was kannst du
sagen über die auswirkungen dieses
angriffs handynetz habt ihr zum glück
noch senden denn die fernsehstation
weiterhin
bei mir war es genauso wie bei paul das
ist sehr außerhalb wir haben das auch
erst extern erfahren die handys gehen
noch alle bei uns das tv der sender der
ukrainische sender ist eingestellt die
anderen funktionieren noch die sind
nicht betroffen aber was eben im vorfeld
auch gewarnt worden ist seitens der
russin das eben telekommunikation oder
der einrichtungs gebäude die telekom
oder telekommunikation beinhalten
angegriffen werden da haben sie
angeblich immerhin schon gewarnt dass
wenn zivilisten dort in der nähe sind
dass dort evakuiert werden soll dann
wurde auch gewarnt dass ein so genanntes
info psychologisches zentrum des
ukrainischen geheimdienst bombardiert
werden sollte also man versucht jetzt
ganz klar die
kommunikationsschnittstelle der
ukrainischen armee und der bevölkerung
zu durchbrechen das ist das erste in
einer kriegsführung einer
psychologischen kriegsführung auch
taktisch dass ich eben die
kommunikationswege
zerstöre das heißt ich will unterbinden
dass eben mein gegner hier auf dem grund
weiß was der andere macht das heißt auf
deutsch gesagt was man richtig sagt es
geht los das ist erst der anfang weil
danach kommen andere infrastrukturelle
andere militär militärische ziele werden
dann ins visier genommen um dann eben
einen größeren angriff einzuleiten paul
kommt die nachrichte heran über unsere
kanäle dass vitali klitschko der
bürgermeister von kirche auf telegramm
bekanntgegeben hat der feind greift die
hauptstadt an das würde also bedeuten
dass es tatsächlich losgeht als wir
vorhin gesprochen hast du gerade ich
glaube es war vladimir der nicht gerade
angerufen hatte während wir diese
schalter gemacht haben was kannst du
dazu sagen
ja ich habe tatsächlich nervöse stimmung
wahrgenommen beim bürgermeister der
stadt und auch emotionen was gerade hier
in seiner stadt die ihr seid 2014
regiert kurz nach dem majdan zweimal im
amt bestätigt miterlebt er organisiert
vor allem die zivilen und die probleme
die dadurch entstehen durch die durch
den krieg als die versorgungslinien um
die er sich kümmern muss und natürlich
war das alles absehbar aber das zu
erleben als bürgermeister das ist jetzt
tatsächlich losgeht dass man ins zentrum
offenbar vorstoßen will dass wladimir
putin nicht aufhört mit bomben und
wahrscheinlich luftangriffen das ist
etwas was man auch erst einmal verdauen
muss aber natürlich ist vitali klitschko
und die anderen den verantwortung sind
hier kämpfer und die werden kämpfen das
hat er mehrfach angekündigt aber
natürlich ist das der beginn auf einer
sehr kritischen zeit für vitali
klitschko wir wissen dass er genauso wie
sie lenski auf listen steht und wir
wissen dass wladimir putin
todsünde geht da noch mal kurze zurück
zu dir ja wir rüsten sich jetzt die
menschen für diese sechste kriegs nacht
in folge die entscheidende kriegs markt
ja sehr wahrscheinlich also ja wie wird
die verteidigung der stadt aussehen wie
wird das organisiert
naja so eine stadt wird dann meistens
über einen verteidigungslinien
eingeteilt die äußere linie die fängt
dann meistens bei den brücken an da kann
es sein dass dort wahrscheinlich wenn es
wirklich hart auf hart kommt dann die
ukrainischen streitkräfte einige brücken
strenge sprengen um zu verhindern dass
russische einheiten bodeneinheiten
vorrücken können dann gibt es innere
verteidigungslinien die natürlich mit
rot blogs mit mit stellungen mit
ausgehobenen stellung in der stadt
beginnen und dann gibt es den
sogenannten partisan stellungskampf das
sind eben die
zigtausend bürger die jetzt hier in kiew
in der innenstadt und in den
außenbezirken quasi in ihren wohnungen
in ihren versteckten getarnten
stellungen mit ihren automatischen
gewehren panzerfäusten sprengfallen
molotow-cocktails etc warten dass die
russische armee hier einmarschiert und
wir glauben alle hier dass das die
schwierigste prüfung sein wird und auch
das gefährlichste für die russische
armee denn da ist nichts mehr mit
technologie da ist auch nichts mehr mit
digitalisierung das ist konventionelle
partisan kriegsführung und da kann ein
sag ich mal zwei euro molotow-cocktail 1
2 bis 5 millionen dollar panzer
zerstören das geht dann so einfach also
da stehen die russen dann quasi einer
ganz hoch motivierten partisanen armee
gegenüber die hand in hand mit der
regulären armee kämpft und das ist
glaube ich das was die russen am meisten
fürchten was jetzt beginnt ist erst mal
der äußere
ring beziehungsweise jetzt die
zerstörung der kommunikation und dann
ist auch damit zu rechnen dass es zu
luftschlägen kommt wahrscheinlich nicht
durch die luftwaffe weil die luftabwehr
der ukraine scheint ja noch zu
funktionieren
die russen haben auch noch keinen
flughafen hier besetzen können das heißt
sie konnten auch noch kein brückenkopf
hier bilden also das ist er
ausgeschlossen wahrscheinlich dann eher
mit gezielten schlägen durch
marschflugkörper die dann in die
entsprechenden
infrastrukturellen gebäude
reingeschossen werden oder auch in
stellung paul wir bekommen gerade
nochmal über unsere kanäle die nachricht
herein dass witali klitschko gesagt
hatte der turm der fernsehturm sei
beschädigt worden und auch das daran
liegende umspannwerk sei beschädigt
worden so dass also die funktionen dort
beeinträchtigt sind das in dem moment wo
ebenfalls die nachricht kommt dass er
bundeskanzler olaf scholz noch einmal
mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten
selensky telefoniert hat was bedeutet
das jetzt für sie lenski wenn
tatsächlich und vielleicht muss man ja
mit weiteren angriffen rechnen mit der
fernsehturm wirklich ausgeschaltet wird
wenn sie lenz gesichtern über fernsehen
beispielsweise auch nicht mehr mit
seinen mut macht rede ans volk wenden
kann die ja jetzt so wichtig sind zum
durchhalten
wenn einer anderen kanäle gefunden hat
auf dieser welt als präsident dann ist
das motto müsse lenski der fast in den
vergangenen tagen und wochen
ausschließlich per social media
kommuniziert hat das dann wieder weiter
getragen wurde in die medien der sich
per twitter per facebook für instagram
an die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
gewendet hat das ginge theoretisch noch
und für sie lenz wie wir das auch
wahrscheinlich weiter möglich sein denn
er hat möglichkeiten dass er auch
weiterhin netz hat natürlich als
präsident und in seinem umfeld
allerdings glaube ich ist das viel
größere problem
neben dem fernsehturm die frage was
passiert wenn das internet im land
ausfällt ich glaube das würde dann
bedeuten dass die menschen eben diese
mut machen messages von selensky nicht
mehr empfangen könnten er könnte zwar
senden aber die menschen könnten das
nicht mehr empfangen und das könnte dann
zu großer panik großer verunsicherung
führen und das ist ja das was russland
erreichen will hier was wladimir putin
erreichen will er will panik erreichen
er will dafür sorgen dass die menschen
angst kriegen dass sie zweifeln auch und
dann will hier rein gehen und am ende
dafür sorgen das ist ein schreckens
regime eine marionettenregierung hier
installiert wird das ist auch das muss
einmal hier zur seite schauen das ist
auch das was ihnen den
geheimdienstberichten ja immer wieder
genannt wurde sein ursprünglicher plan
war ein schneller krieg mit möglichst
wenigen zivilen opfern und dann die
installierung einer marionettenregierung
der haken peter hatte schon angesprochen
ist die große der große widerstand den
mann jetzt in der form noch gar nicht
sehen kann aber wir können ihnen fühlen
weil wir dort die menschen sehen mit den
waffen in den straßen peter hat heute
beeindruckende bilder gefilmt wie
menschen dort waffen verteilt haben wie
immer noch neue waffen reinkommen das
ist das was wir es dann sehen werden
wenn russische soldaten in der stadt
sind und das wird ganz anders aussehen
als in den anderen städten in der eu wo
wir gesehen haben wie panzer eingefahren
sind das standen dann zwar hunderte
ukraine sehr sehr mutig und haben gegen
dem russischen einmarsch protestiert
aber in diesen dörfern städten da wurden
jetzt nicht großflächig waffen verteilt
der krieg der kampf und die frage wer
diesen krieg gewinnt konzentriert sich
auf kiew das ist das symbol das ist die
hauptstadt hier wird alles entschieden
jetzt haben wir ja den ganzen tag über
diese bilder verfolgt von diesem
ellenlangen konvoi 64 kilometer lang der
sich auf den weg gemacht hat in die
ukrainische hauptstadt nach kiew heißt
das im umkehrschluss es geht jetzt los
bei euch dass dieser konvoi jetzt
angekommen ist
peter ich gehe davon aus dass dieser
soll du darfst auch gerne antworten paar
okay ich gehe davon aus dass dieser
kunde neu
gar nicht so diese entscheidende rolle
momentan spielt das ist natürlich
beängstigend das ängstigt auch die
menschen natürlich in der ukraine wenn
man diesen 60 kilometer konvoi sieht
aber es geht vor allem momentan um den
beschuss des tv turms der
stromversorgung des internets und das
passiert mit raketen das passiert
sozusagen mit zielgerichteten
einschlägen und die frage des konvois
wird erst dann eine rolle spielt wenn du
laden putin das ganz große raketen
besteck sozusagen aus geholt hat und
hier schon einiges zerstört hat erst
dann würden bodentruppen hereinkommen es
wird dunkel hinter euch peter dieser
angriff auf den fernsehturm und die
gefahr das internet lahm zu legen was
bedeutet das für eure arbeit
na ja wir können so lange arbeiten wie
auch die kommunikation funktioniert das
heißt wenn wir auch abgeschnitten werden
das heißt wir hätten kein internet dann
sieht's auch dunkel aus wir haben dann
auch keinen zugriff mehr auf quellen es
ist dann analog natürlich alles was
natürlich nicht was eingeschränkt wird
weil wir auch eine ausgangssperre haben
also unser bewegungsraum ist relativ
eingeschränkt dann ab 8 uhr ist schon
wieder ist schon wieder ende wird
öffentlich auf die straße bis 7 uhr
morgens und das wird dann halt sehr
schwierig wir haben natürlich noch
satellitentelefone et cetera aber das
ist natürlich auch sinn und zweck dann
für eine psychologische kriegsführung
was die russen erreichen wollen das
einzige was sie nicht haben möchten ist
sind bilder bilder die der wahrheit
entsprechen und dass die dann noch in
die welt hinausgetragen werden das ist
das allerschlimmste für sie das hält sie
allerdings nicht davon ab weiter zu
machen und solange wir sehen können und
solange wir schwimmen können werden wir
das natürlich machen peter und paul
ronzheimer in kiel vielen dank an euch
beide ja es gibt breaking news denn es
gibt tatsächlich fünf tote und fünf
verletzte bei diesem angriff auf den
fernsehturm in kiew das meldet zumindest
die käfer stadtverwaltung will die
bilder unten noch einmal vor gut einer
stunde einen angriff auf den fernsehturm
in kiew das ist ein strategisches ziel
natürlich um die kommunikation
auszuschalten in tier in der hauptstadt
dort und es ist kein guter vorbote für
das was heute noch bevorsteht